Від більшості пам'ятників його товаришам по партії - більшовикам - в процесі декомунізації в Україні
залишилися хіба що постаменти - принаймні на контрольованій Києвом території.
Проте радянський революціонер Артем, друг Сталіна
і засновник Донецько-Криворізької Республіки - такого собі прототипу ДНР, встояв.
Від декомунізації велетенську статую у курортному містечку Святогірськ, що на Донбасі,
врятував статус пам’ятки монументального мистецтва національного значення -
адже створив її знаменитий український скульптор Іван Кавалерідзе.
Втім, від впливу часу і сил природи монумент це не захистило.
Он - все геть потріскане. Ось - воно все сиплеться.
Така от якість. Хіба це бетон? Це не бетон.
Реставратор пам’ятника, 70-річний мешканець Краматорська Юрій Перебийніс,
пам'ятає Артема у кращі його часи.
Як і багато мешканців Донбасу, він з дитинства приїздив до Святогірська на відпочинок.
З того часу монумент дуже занепав.
Адже будували пам’ятник у середині 20-х років з неякісних матеріалів - через брак коштів.
А реставрували востаннє - у 1983 році, до сторіччя більшовика Артема.
До того ж, п’ять років тому, невдовзі після початку війни на Донбасі,
засновника Донецько-Криворізької республіки ледь не "декомунізувала" блискавка.
Блискавка влучила йому в голову - і пішла далі вниз.
Вона вибила близько пів кубічного метра матеріалу.
Ми знов залили туди приблизно півкуба бетону.
Відновлювати пам’ятник почали з голови - тепер треба спускатися вниз.
Запломбували голову Артема наприкінці минулого року.
Тоді ж реставратори встановили на голові революціонера блискавковідвід.
Але те, що з обласного бюджету на ремонт пам’ятника більшовику
виділили майже 400 тисяч гривень, у Києві сподобалося не всім.
Адже Артем - справжнє ім’я Федір Сергеєв - в Україні відомий перш за все як засновник
Донецько-Криворізької Радянської республіки, що вів активну боротьбу проти УНР.
Віце-прем’єр В’ячеслав Кириленко, дізнавшись про реставрацію,
зажадав її перевірки Інститутом національної пам’яті.
Артема назвав "більшовицьким терористом та сепаратистом".
Утім, монумент відстояли.
Адже він - пам'ятка мистецтва національного значення - як унікальний витвір у стилі кубізму
Івана Кавалерідзе, кажуть у Святогірському державному історико-архітектурному заповіднику.
І наголошують: рятують не пам’ять про більшовика-сепаратиста,
а роботу видатного українського скульптора.
Ми не за Артема - хай його історія судить. Але Іван Кавалерідзе - це наш український Мікеланджело.
Ми за нього боремось, відстоюємо і зберігаємо для нащадків.
За весь цей період дуже неспокійний, м’яко кажучи, не було ніяких актів вандалізму.
Жодного такого напису немає,
як-от писали на пам’ятнику Леніну - що кат і так далі.
Немає нічого і не було, слава тобі Господи.
У регіоні просто люди ліниві живуть - ліньки на гору підніматися. Жартую.
Як організатор робітничого руху,
Артем на початку 20-го століття встиг прославитися навіть в Австралії, де перебував в еміграції.
Серед австралійських колег революціонер мав прізвисько "Big Tom" - "Великий Том".
Зараз його гігантська статуя стала туристичною візитівкою Святогірська.
Попри аварійність споруди подивитися на неї щодня приїжджають десятки туристів.
Пам’ятник подобається всім - хоча багато хто навіть не знає, хто це.
Вождь світового пролетаріату.
Пам’ятник мені дуже сподобався. Це героям, які тут воювали у Велику вітчизняну війну.
Був у нас такий революціонер - Сергєєв. Це йому пам’ятник.
Він наш - артемівський. Це наша історія. Як можна нашу історію губити.
З одного боку, це архітектурна пам’ятка. З іншого боку, якщо є декомунізація, то її слід проводити.
Зараз нова влада все перекручує. До 14-го року був герой, після 14-го - сепаратист.
Я думаю, його потрібно відновити.
Гарний пам’ятник у красивому місці. Якщо б його ще відреставрувати!
Недалеко від монумента - одна з найголовніших святинь Московського патріархату -
Святогірська Лавра.
Ми вирішуємо спитати в монастирі, чи не заважає братії сусідство з більшовиком Артемом.
У Лаврі нас зустрічає намісник монастиря - митрополит Арсеній.
Те, що пам’ятник залишили, вважає правильним. Але пояснення чому - у нього особливе.
У нас був старець Ісаакій, якого прозвали Ісаакій-прозорливець.
Знаючи його дар прозріння, кажуть:
"Отець Ісаакій, от якби там на тій горі поставити церкву або капличку Вознесіння Господнього".
Він довго дивився на гору, потім сказав:
"Браття, нічого там не будуйте. Я там церкви не бачу. Я там здорового чолов’ягу бачу".
Що за чолов’яга, тоді ніхто не зрозумів. Отець Ісаакій помер у 1903 році.
Тому дехто дивиться на Артема як на пам’ятку якоїсь ідеології,
а я дивлюся на нього як на пам’ятку прозорливості отця Ісаакія.
Щоб дізнатися, чи є у пам’ятника Артему вороги на Донбасі - окрім блискавок, їдемо в Бахмут.
Це місто протягом майже століття мало назву Артемівськ -
на честь Артема, який працював тут у перші роки радянської влади.
Історичну назву місту, розташованому за 30 кілометрів від лінії фронту,
повернули лише у 2016 році.
У рамках декомунізації перейменували також вулицю Артема
і сім провулків, які носили ім’я більшовика.
А пам’ятник Артему, що раніше стояв у центрі Бахмута,
зараз зберігається у тролейбусному депо - у компанії з Леніним.
Громадська активістка Галина Олійникова
безпосередньо брала участь у декомунізації Бахмута.
Каже, між подіями 100-річної давнини та сьогоденням можна провести багато паралелей.
Артем - це відомий міжнародний терорист.
Новоросія, "ДНР", "ЛНР" - це ідея, яка пішла від Артема.
Артем є сакральною фігурою для тих сепаратистів і терористів, які зараз воюють на Донбасі.
Втім, попри свою непримириму позицію щодо інших пам’ятників Артему і назв на його честь,
монумент у Святогірську потрібно зберегти, переконана активістка.
Це є витвір мистецтва роботи великого майстра Кавалерідзе у стилі кубізм,
і таких пам’ятників не багато у світі.
Саме тому його треба зберегти.
Нам потрібен музей тоталітаризму.
Святогірськ є туристичною Меккою області.
Біля самого пам’ятника Артему є майданчик - от туди звезти всі пам’ятники,
які ще лишилися в області, і там їх встановити.
Такі речі дійсно людям треба залишати в пам’яті.
Нагадувати, хто вони, де вони, через що вони пройшли.
А тим більше нам, коли уже шостий рік іде війна, треба знати, звідки вона почалася.
Щоб врятувати шедевр Кавалерідзе від природної "декомунізації",
реставраторам доведеться працювати декілька місяців.
Кажуть, пришвидшити ремонт не вдасться - заважатиме спека.
Але до кінця року сподіваються встигнути - якщо вистачить коштів.
Обіцяють: після реставрації святогірський Артем простоїть щонайменше чверть століття -
до наступного ремонту.